On the other side, someone who's not doing
so well, Donald Trump's property values
have plummeted. It's insane what is going
on with Donald Trump's property values.
Trump branded Manhattan buildings have lost
half of their value since Donald Trump first
took office properties that used to have the
Trump name. But don't any more have lost 17
percent of their value, it is believed, it seems,
that the Trump brand name is a disaster right now.
And I am wondering whether at some point
in time, if he doesn't already, Donald
Trump is going to regret or end up regretting
this entire presidential run and presidency.
Urban digs looked at the seven luxury
buildings in Manhattan that have the Trump name
and three that used to be Trump branded
buildings, but had the Trump branding removed.
And they are all doing disastrously. And what's
hilarious about this to me is that we've covered
over the years Donald Trump's funny business with
property valuations. We know that when Donald
Trump wants a loan or a line of credit against one
of his properties, he will inflate the value of
the property and claim it is worth much more than
it's really worth. On the other hand, when Donald
Trump is trying to minimize taxes or to, for
other reasons, benefit from lower property values,
he will just argue that his property values are
much lower than they probably are. In reality,
it seems as though Donald Trump is going to have
no problem arguing for lower property values
for the upcoming years for tax purposes, because
they really are collapsing. And in in some sense,
I mean, the Trump we've talked before about
how Trump spent his life essentially trying
to stay away from the people that make
up the vast majority of his supporters.
I know that Trump has some wealthy supporters,
but a lot of the folks that support Trump
are the folks from the parts of the country that
Trump has never been a big fan of and people who
economically are not the people that Donald Trump
is trying to spend time around. And in that sense,
his presidency has been terrible marketing for his
business. The people who, like Trump, can't afford
to live in his buildings. Many of them can't
even afford to go to Donald Trump's hotels,
which, by the way, are also looking quite sparse,
not exactly bustling from videos that have been
released lately. Pandemic understood. Certainly a
factor. So in a sense, Trump's constituents from
a presidential standpoint are not the folks that
are Trump's business customers. And that may well
prove to be yet another disaster as things
go forward. Just to put some numbers to it.
Back in 2016, the average price per square foot
at seven of Trump's properties was around thirty
three hundred dollars per square foot, very, very
high. And in twenty seventeen, that was down to
nineteen hundred dollars a square foot. In twenty
twenty it was sixteen dollars a square foot. And
who knows now where those numbers are going to be.
Bearing in mind part of the decrease is less about
Trump, but about what's going on with the virus
potentially. But luxury properties have not been
as affected as some other areas of the economy.
So I don't know what the answer is in terms of
if you got an honest answer from Trump, do you
regret running for president? Has this all been
a disaster for you? We know that Ivanka and Jared
are not particularly. Welcome back. In New York
City, we saw the wanted posters all over Manhattan
when it was revealed that they were hoping to go
back to New York City after the end of Donald
Trump's reign of terror in Washington, D.C..
If you got them in a room and they were really
honest with you and I don't know if they would be.
To some degree, it's hard to imagine that they're
that thrilled. I mean, I think on the one hand,
it's sort of a balancing between on the
one hand, these are narcissistic people
and there's a thirst for power where it's so
appealing and attractive, the presidency and
being at the White House and all of that. On the
other hand, the social circles they were part of
are widely speaking, shunning them. The people
that want them around are the people they try
to stay away from their entire lives and their
businesses while still functioning. Businesses
may now be number one, worth far less and far less
profitable than they ever were. And they are going
to be dealing with investigations into all sorts
of possible financial wrongdoing for the next
very many years. I don't know how great the entire
presidency and politics experience has been for
the Trump family. And I'm not sure if they're even
coming clean with themselves about it. Never mind
whether they would come clean with someone in
a room if they knew it wasn't being recorded.
What do you think what do you think is the
Trump family's honest perspective on what this
presidency has done for them? Let me know. You
can find me on Twitter at David Pakman and you
can find the show on Twitter at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman
Dotcom. OK, let's hear from some folks of the
The David Pakman Show discord,
David Pakman dotcom slash discord.